bonsoir et bienvenue dans Ça vous
regarde ce soir un historien qui raconte
sa propre histoire bonsoir Benjamin
Stora ravi de vous accueillir l'arrivée
chez Taillandier c'est la vôtre de
Constantine à Paris
1962-1972 et c'est de loin votre livre
le plus intime le plus personnel un
hommage à vos parents on en parlera à
vous raconter votre rapport à l'exil
mais aussi la société française et ça
résonne forcément avec l'actualité
marquée par l'immigration ces derniers
jours on va en parler ensemble dans la
deuxième partie notre grand débat ce
soir faut-il régionaliser le SMIC c'est
Valérie Pécresse qui jette ce pavé dans
la mare la Présidente de la Région
Île-de-France veut augmenter le salaire
minimum des Franciliens face au coût de
la vie qui explose à Paris souhaitable
faisable nous ont des bâtons dans un
instant avec nos invités sur ce plateau
enfin nos affranchis ce soir il y a le
Goose pour son parti pris politique
Pierre-Henri tavoyau la vie des idées et
un bonbon Express très royal avec
Stéphanie Despierres voilà pour le
programme on y va Benjamin in Stora ça
vous regarde c'est parti
alors un petit problème de générique
mais c'est pas bien grave parce qu'on va
tout de suite débattre de cette idée qui
a tout mais vraiment tout pour plaire
augmenter le SMIC là où la vie est plus
chère à l'heure où la fin du mois
commence le 10 c'est bien la proposition
de Valérie Pécresse n'est pas passée
inaperçue 1383 euros par mois quand plus
de la moitié pardon le loyer c'est tout
simplement indigne à juger la présidente
de l'île de France alors pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas régionaliser le salaire
minimum bonsoir Jean-François Vigier et
merci d'être là c'est vous qui êtes à
l'origine de cette proposition vous
présidez le groupe
udi au conseil régional Île-de-France
c'est à vous donc Valérie Pécresse a
confié une mission pour un choc de
décentralisation dans laquelle figure
cette fameuse idée d'un SMIC régional
bonsoir Erwan banana merci d'être avec
nous et députés modem du Finistère vous
nous direz si la majorité peut compter
voilà sur sur cette idée la soutenir ou
pas bonsoir Christophe Selzer ravi de
vous accueillir vous dirigez le signe
tank libéral génération libre on s'en
souvient fondé par Gaspard Koenig enfin
bonsoir Gilbert 7 impossible de faire ce
débat sans vous parce que vous êtes le
grand spécialiste des questions du SMIC
vous êtes économiste et professeur à
Neoma Business School vous présidez ce
groupe d'experts qui a été mis en place
par le gouvernement qui rend chaque
année un rapport sur l'impact du SMIC
sur notre économie Benjamin Stora
n'hésitez pas à intervenir quand vous le
souhaitez c'est une longue histoire
aussi le SMIC donc je suis sûr que vous
aurez quelques remarques à nous
soumettre avant de vous donner la parole
les faits donc la proposition en
question puis les réactions vois cela
dans le chrono de Blacko qu'on accueille
tout de suite
bonsoir mon cher Stéphane bonsoir Myriam
je me retourne je vous invite à faire la
même chose pour accueillir Stéphane
blackovski alors ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que Valérie Pécresse a de la suite
dans les idées on peut lui reconnaître
ça au moins puisque vous vous souvenez
qu'en 2022 la promesse phare de sa
campagne présidentielle c'était
d'augmenter de 10% les salaires bien
cette semaine elle enfonce le clou elle
veut toujours augmenter les salaires
mais cette fois-ci son projet c'est
d'augmenter de 9%, le SMIC en
Île-de-France qui est ça tombe bien
justement la région
quel président donc sa proposition elle
repose sur une étude de l'INSEE qui
disait en 2015 que le différence de prix
entre région parisienne et provinces et
de 9%. alors ce qui est un peu bizarre
c'est d'avoir choisi l'étude de 2015
alors que l'INSEE en a fait une en 2022
donc ce qui aurait été plus d'actualité
qui nous dit que la différence en fait
est plutôt de 7% bon chipoter on
comprend l'idée qu'il y a derrière ça
c'est que tout le monde s'accorde et le
sait la vie est plus chère en région
parisienne qu'en province et selon
l'inse l'explication tient surtout sur
les loyers qui sont en moyenne 40%
supérieures en région parisienne par
rapport à la province alors je vous
montre une carte pour illustrer ces
grosses disparités au niveau national si
vous achetez un studio de 25 mètres à
Paris ça coûte 267000 euros actuellement
25 mètres carrés c'est un studio on
considère la taille d'un studio bien
pour le même prix la même somme vous
pouvez avoir 60 m² à bord de Wanis vous
pouvez avoir 70 mètres carrés à Rennes
ou à Strasbourg 90 m² à Marseille et
puis alors si vous voulez vraiment de la
place Saint-Étienne on a 200 mètres
carrés donc c'est cet argument du prix
du logement sur lequel insiste
évidemment Valérie Pécresse pour
justifier une hausse du SMIC
particulièrement en Île-de-France on
l'écoute vous êtes Mika vous gagnez le
SMIC si vous voulez vous loger avec dans
un studio à Créteil c'est 50% de votre
salaire qui va y passer si vous voulez
vous loger à Limoges ce sera 25%. donc
vous voyez bien que le reste à vivre
pour les bas salaires est très faible
puis alors il y a un autre argument
qu'on peut loyer pour défendre un SMIC
différent d'une région à l'autre c'est
que ça déjà existé cette idée c'était le
cas jusqu'en 1968 donc si on l'a fait
avant rien n'empêche de refaire
aujourd'hui ce qui est curieux c'est que
Olivier du socle qui lui est opposé à
cette idée emplois exactement le même
argument si on a arrêté cette idée en
1968 il y a bien une raison et la raison
c'est que ça ne marchait pas on l'écoute
le SMIC différent d'un endroit à l'autre
ça a déjà existé de 1950 à 1968 et ça a
été abandonné parce que d'abord les
écarts de niveau de vie de loyer ne sont
pas forcément à l'échelle d'une région
en région Île-de-France le prix le coût
de la vie le coût des loyers n'est pas
le même dans toutes les communes alors
pour illustrer le propos du ministre on
peut citer des chiffres sans même parler
de Paris où le prix du mètre carré
dépasse les 10000 euros vous voyez que
dans les Hauts-de-Seine le prix du mètre
carré est au-dessus de 7000 euros et en
revanche en Seine-et-Marne le prix du
mètre carré est en dessous de 3000 euros
et pourtant les deux département S sont
dans la région Île-de-France alors
est-ce qu'il faudrait filmer ce qu'il
faudrait faire un SMIC non pas par
région mais un SMIC par département vous
êtes même un speak par commune bon je
sais pas ça paraît un petit peu
compliqué mais mais c'est pas parce que
le gouvernement n'est pas d'accord qu'on
a pas le droit de débattre de cette idée
on y va alors Jean-François visé puisque
c'est vous qui êtes à l'origine de cette
proposition qu'est-ce qui vous fait
penser que cette fois-ci ça pourrait
marcher puisqu'on l'a déjà essayé pour
le ministre du Travail vous l'entendez
ça n'a pas fonctionné
sont géniteurs Pierre-Yves Cossé qui
était commissaire au Plan d'ailleurs à
l'époque a affirmé à plusieurs reprises
qu'il regrettait cette décision de
l'avoir nationalisée mais avant de
rentrer dans le vif du sujet sur le SMIC
permettez-moi quand même de
recontextualiser cette proposition et je
pense que c'est très important en fait
la présidence m'a confié il y a un an
une mission vous l'avez dit pour un choc
de décentralisation à l'issue de
l'adoption par le Parlement par
l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat d'une
loi qui s'est appelée la loi 3DS et qui
avait pour objectif pour ambition de
donner plus de liberté aux collectivités
locales parce que c'est un débat
aujourd'hui dans notre pays celui de
faire descendre les compétences vers les
collectivités région villes départements
dès lors que la présidente m'a confié
cette mission j'ai organisé des
auditions qui ont duré un an à l'issue
desquels nous avons
identifié 40 nouvelles compétences
demandées à l'état
dans quel cas nous avons pu demander ces
nouvelles compétences c'est que quand la
loi 3DS a été adoptée et c'est assez
incroyable beaucoup d'élus ont été déçus
des résultats de cette loi malgré les
efforts des sénateurs pour essayer de la
renforcer mais il y a une notion qui est
passée complètement sous les radars à
l'occasion de l'adoption de cette loi
c'est la notion de différenciation c'est
que le législateur a permis de dire à
une région que sur des aspects sociétaux
sociaux économiques elle pouvait se
sentir en différence avec les autres
régions et à ce titre demandez un
aménagement de ses compétences ou de
nouvelles compétences
la différenciation sur le SMIC en
Île-de-France parce que la ville Suchère
et c'est dans ce cadre que nous avons
identifié 40 nouvelles demandes que j'ai
présentées que j'ai eu l'honneur
présenté à la demande de la
présidentière à l'assemblée régionale
qui ont été adoptées 45 à l'arrivée avec
des mesures sur le SMIC totalement je
réalise je termine juste sur la
procédure puisque c'est intéressant on a
un parlementaire de la majorité c'est
que nous allons maintenant saisir
officiellement le gouvernement et le
gouvernement de par la loi a un an pour
nous répondre donc ce que nous ouvrons
aujourd'hui c'est un débat avec le
gouvernement à qui nous demandons chiche
nous avons 45 propositions de
compétences discutons regardons comment
vous plaidez pour cette mesure votre
votre journaliste a dit plusieurs choses
très intéressantes d'abord il y a une
différence de coût de la vie entre la
Région Île-de-France et les autres
régions françaises qui est extrêmement
importante
on a un coût du logement qui est
beaucoup plus élevé qu'ailleurs et on a
vu les chiffres actuellement et nous
avons aujourd'hui toute un cas de
francilien qui ne peuvent pas
évidemment c'est le premier budget mais
l'alimentation aussi dans les transports
c'est la différence on va avoir le débat
parce que c'est un des vrais sujets
voilà et donc de ce fait il faut que
nous demandions de par cette
différenciation la capacité à ce que il
y a une fixation régionale du SMIC de
façon à pouvoir adapter le salaire
minimum au coût de la vie en Île de
France
Erwan après tout ça déjà existé et puis
ça existe aujourd'hui vous le savez il y
a des pays le Portugal par exemple à
deux régions dans lequel ça se passe le
Mexique aussi et aux États-Unis le SMIC
est fixé par les États les États
fédéraux
un État fédéral fédéré avec des états
fédéraux les États-Unis donc c'est il y
a une différence moi je comprends que
les les élus parisiens et on vit de se
préoccuper des Parisiens et des
habitants de l'Île-de-France c'est
normal il y a des coûts c'est vrai que
le logement est plus cher mais c'est pas
si simple c'est pas si simple et la
différence là qu'on a vu de 7%, si c'est
une différence lycée mais il y a
d'autres endroits en France et d'autres
territoires
où vous avez un coût de la vie qui est
important et je pense par exemple c'est
pas la même chose que les Hauts-de-Seine
en Bretagne à certains endroits où vous
habitez loin de l'endroit où vous
travaillez donc du transport et du
transport en voiture qui coûte très cher
et qu'en plus vous habitez dans une zone
tendue et que vous avez du mal à trouver
un logement je peux vous assurer que
c'est pas c'est aussi compliqué donc
l'enjeu en réalité c'est d'augmenter les
salaires c'est d'augmenter les salaires
dans ce pays et d'augmenter le SMIC et
d'augmenter
d'augmenter la capacité
modèle
en augmentant le SMIC à Paris vous le
baissez ailleurs
un autre endroit il est plus bas donc
voyez bien qu'il y a une différence et
il faut donner la capacité
nationale et avec les oppositions de la
nuque qui demandait l'augmentation du
SMIC
augmenter le SMIC c'est pas c'est la
conférence sociale c'est pas le c'est
pas le gouvernement qui augmente le SPIC
dans un pays c'est c'est
partenaires sociaux je suis désolé c'est
les partenaires sociaux en accord
ensemble et un travail que qu'on va
avoir grâce à la conférence sociale
et sur la question des salaires parce
que le vrai sujet des salaires c'est
effectivement le salaire de base en
France qui est sans doute pas suffisant
mais c'est aussi l'évolution des
salaires c'est à dire qu'on commence
vous êtes une femme vous commencez au
SMIC vous finissez au SMIC votre
carrière c'est pas possible ça c'est
là-dessus qu'il faut qu'on travaille
plus que sur des différenciations qui je
le redis posent certains nombre de
problèmes parce que je le redis ce n'est
pas si évident que la vie
alors on va aller voir le spécialiste de
la question du SMIC l'économiste Gilbert
7 merci d'être à distance avec nous je
vous ai lu dans Le Parisien ce matin au
départ le groupe d'experts que vous
présidez regardez avec plutôt
bienveillance cette proposition et puis
vous avez de changer d'avis pourquoi oui
on a changé d'avis mais juste avant de
revenir sur ce point j'aurais quand même
signalé que depuis le 1er janvier 2021
le SMIC a été augmenté à cette reprise
cette reprise et l'augmenter au total de
13,5 %. et voilà ont connu une
augmentation de salaire de 13e 5 vous
voyez c'est comme des éléments à mettre
à mettre au débat alors maintenant pour
revenir sur votre question effectivement
nous avons nous sommes penchés sur cette
proposition qui est très très ancienne
aussi ancienne que la création du SMIC
c'est-à-dire le début de l'année 1970
c'est pas la fin de l'année 1968 donc
depuis le début de l'année 1970 il y a
toujours eu des propositions de
rérégionalisation du salaire minimum
nous avons voulu étudier ça sur le fond
et au début nous l'avons étudié avec
beaucoup de bienveillance comme vous le
rappelez cette idée semblait c'est
logique finalement niveau des prix du
Balmain en région parisienne que dans
d'autres régions de France et en
regardant attentivement les choses nous
avons constaté que ça a été présenté
tout à l'heure que la principale
de départ de prix d'un lieu en France
c'était le loyer c'est ça quand même la
principale il y a d'autres sources mais
qui qui joue de façon très faible par
rapport à l'épée des écarts de loyer et
puis ces effets ces écarts de loyer de
prix du logement ne sont pas je dirais
au niveau d'une région par rapport à une
autre mais sont beaucoup plus
granulaires comme ça a été signé tout à
l'heure c'est une ville par rapport à
dire si on voulait garantir par le SMIC
une constante une égalité du pouvoir
d'achat
pour toutes les régions et pour tous les
lieux d'habitation en France il faudrait
faire nous pas 9 dysmique il faudrait en
faire des dizaines de milliers
l'analyse que nous on a cette
argumenté donc il nous a semblé que
c'était très compliqué et qu'il y avait
d'autres urgences dans le débat sur le
SMIC et celui-là et j'aurais rappelé
d'ailleurs c'est un point important que
le SMIC est payé par l'employeur
si on a on va dans la direction qui
évoquait suggéré ici
selon la localisation de l'employeur il
y aurait un niveau du SMIC différent
mais de salariés vit pas forcément dans
la localité où et son entreprise donc
oui on est quand même dans des grosses
difficultés ici on prendra pas
réellement en compte par une mesure de
ce type là les écarts de niveau 2 prix
on va revenir vers vous Gilbert 7
peut-être qu'on peut essayer essayer de
régler un tout petit peu plus votre
votre micro afin que le son soit soit
optimal c'est un argument de poids quand
même c'est pas 1 2 3 4 SMIC mais des
milliers de Smic différents en fonction
des communes Christophe Felter c'est
c'est une usine à gaz qui est
complètement imposable non
d'abord enfin comme directeur d'un film
tank qui a parmi ces grands combats la
des présidentialisation en régime plus
parlementaire la simplification et la
décentralisation je voudrais enfin je
pense qu'il faut absolument saluer
l'initiative du Conseil régional parce
que cette proposition qui est la
première des 45 compétences que le
Conseil régional demande à obtenir
aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose de
révolutionnaire en tant que tel c'est
une formation concrètement
c'est très très rare c'est conforme au
principe de subsidiarité ascendante
qu'on défend
je trouve que cette proposition à la
vertu de montrer que le fait de décréter
un niveau national partout ce que
devrait être technique alors qu'il y a
effectivement des réalités locales
économiques très différentes c'est
intéressant je pense que ça soulève
notamment effectivement la question du
logement je pense que dans le débat
couvre aujourd'hui le Conseil régional
d'Île-de-France avec l'État en demandant
à s'auto saisir de compétences on
pourrait aussi imaginer l'autre enfin
penser à l'autre versant de la
décentralisation qui est la fiscalité de
l'autonomie fiscale locale nous on
défend le fait que en face de
compétences une collectivité quelle
qu'elle soit puisse lever directement la
peau c'est franchement c'est c'est
presque révolutionnaire en tout cas
radical pour la France qui est qui s'est
construite de façon très jacobine et on
est en train justement de réfléchir à
une refonte de la taxe foncière et de
d'en refaire quelque chose comme une
taxe résidentielle en imaginant même une
ventilation entre ce que paix le
propriétaire est-ce que le pèle
locataire et qui aurait pour vertu en
fait de fluidifier le marché du logement
parce qu'il y a énormément aujourd'hui
des incitations pour les propriétaires à
mettre leur logement
vont très loin je vais repasser la
parole je vois que vous voulez
intervenir peut-être à ce stade du débat
Benjamin sera on entend lever l'impôt au
niveau des collectivités locales un SMIC
dans chaque commune ou chaque
département c'est loin de notre de notre
histoire tout ça les Français pourraient
le comprendre dans l'accepter ben c'est
loin effectivement d'une histoire à
tradition jacobine centralisée de l'État
qui décide par en haut de tout ce que on
doit faire du point de vue des salaires
du point de vue des prix etc etc donc le
fait de fractionner fracturer diversifié
les choses c'est entre guillemets une
petite révolution culturelle je veux
dire dans le cadre de la société
française c'est pas n'importe quoi c'est
donc à apprécier à discuter à mesurer à
peserais quand même précisé que au fur
et à mesure des grands actes de
décentralisation depuis les années 80 en
fait l'État a surtout donné des
compétences aux collectivités en leur
donnant des mais en recentralisant
quasiment toute la fiscalité avant on
avait la taxe d'habitation pour il y
avait de bonnes raisons pour la
supprimer mais en revanche elle avait
une vertu c'était de maintenir un lien
direct entre deux compétences et plus de
moyens pour les mettre en avant on n'a
jamais été aussi peu décentralisé d'un
point de vue fiscal et donc c'est
finalement en
Île-de-France un SMIC à la carte en
fonction du coût de la vie on a grainé
des arguments qu'est-ce que vous
répondez moi déjà sur l'ensemble du
sujet du sujet du pouvoir de vivre des
Français la question du logement elle
est elle est elle est cruciale et elle
est même cardinales puisque on est passé
d'un quart du budget des Français sur le
logement à un tiers du budget c'est
beaucoup hein c'est-à-dire 33% grosso
modo des dépenses de fonctionnement d'un
d'un foyer c'est le logement donc on a
un vrai problème de logement et en plus
on est dans une crise du logement
aujourd'hui il faut avec les taux
d'intérêt qu'il faut résoudre juste sur
le SMIC et sur cette
sur cette différenciation moi je suis
aussi plutôt Girondins que Jacobins
tradition bretonne évidemment mais je
pense que aller dans un SMIC qui serait
différencié et je votre expert l'a dit
je crois qu'il faudrait un SMIC par
commune de France et où au moins minimum
un SMIC par bassin de vie donc ça va
être compliqué extrêmement je remarque
quand même c'était donné dans les
chiffres que le salaire moyen parisien
Île-de-France est plus élevé que le
salaire moyen breton finistérien ou de
mon territoire donc vous voyez que par
ça s'équilibre aussi par parce que font
les efforts que font les les employeurs
pour pour garder leurs salariés pour
être attractif et pour s'adapter à la
réalité moi je reviens vraiment parce
que c'est chez nous un mantra au groupe
moderne c'est qu'il faut qu'on ait un
effort sur les salaires comment comment
on peut faire peut-être même construire
du logement social ça peut être une une
solution aussi et monter faire augmenter
les salaires convaincre les entreprises
de le faire mais on n'a pas entendu les
Franciliens il raconte aussi ce que
c'est que ce reste à vivre réduit à peau
de chagrin une fois avalé par le loyer
c'est un reportage à Paris et en proche
banlieue Marco pommier
je m'appelle madame Coulibaly Salamata
je m'appelle Vincent je m'appelle
Florence je suis assistante de vie aux
familles
je gagne 1300 1400 je paye les loyers
680 euros et maintenant les loyers
arrivaient jusqu'à 735 € par mois
mon loyer c'est 900 980 euros tous les
mois et moi je gagne 1137 euros mon
salaire actuel il est de 1700 euros et
mon loyer me pèse 800 euros
[Musique]
on s'en sort pas du tout au fait pour
que ça soit pas du tout c'est la
catastrophe qu'est-ce qui vous reste à
la fin du mois concrètement rien de tout
que dalle
au reste du cœur et me faire aider par
la famille vous pouvez pas faire
autrement ah non c'est pas possible on
mange pas
on a tout maintenant non que des plats
quand vous rentrez à la maison et que
votre enfant vous dit
que maman j'ai faim et que vous regardez
votre compte bancaire
c'est très difficile d'expliquer le
pourquoi et le comment à vos enfants
c'est très difficile aujourd'hui on ne
vit pas en France on subit
voilà cette réalité elle saute aux yeux
elle prend elle prend au coeur
est-ce qu'on a pas intérêt à trouver
vraiment les leviers si c'est pas le
SMIC régional qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
d'abord je suis très étonné que on lance
un débat il se débat il doit exister et
tout de suite on nous dit non vite non
le SMIC il est national on y touchera
pas parce que c'est comme ça nous on
fait une proposition d'ouvrir le débat
et j'espère que le gouvernement va
vraiment venir discuter avec nous parce
que il s'agit pas de faire 10000 SMIC
déjà vous avez 12 mixes régionaux et
peut-être que il y en aura d'ailleurs
qu'un seul puisque notre demande ne
porte que sur l'Île-de-France il
appartient aux autres régions également
mais le coût de l'énergie dans les
logements
à augmenter de façon terrible pour les
locataires moi je le vois dans ma
commune tous les locataires sont
impactés même dans ma commune où mes
agents publics ont bénéficié aussi d'une
augmentation à plusieurs reprises
décidées par le gouvernement
c'est difficile pour tout le monde de
faire face aux rappels quand même que
abures-sur-yvette un 70 m² en location
c'est environ 1500 euros à Nevers c'est
moitié moins donc on voit bien quand
même qu'il y a un réel problème sur
l'ensemble de l'Île-de-France et qu'il
faut absolument le régler mais derrière
tout ça moi je voudrais dire aussi que
ce qu'on est en train de faire à la
région avec Valérie Pécresse c'est
lancer le débat de la décentralisation
de la liberté des collectivités locales
parce que parmi cette
année à cette mesure quand même
on tient à ouvrir on tient et je tiens à
dire aussi à Monsieur 7 que on va lui
donner tous des spécialistes ne sont pas
d'accord entre eux un gouverneur de la
Banque de France il a dit à plusieurs
reprises que ça vaudrait le coup
d'essayer de régionaliser le SMIC alors
Gilbert 7 va vous répondre on a entendu
le premier argument c'est l'usine à gaz
en fait c'est très clair autant de Smic
que de que de différence communale si
l'on veut deuxième question tous les
économistes vous disent on doit pas
augmenter le SMIC parce que ça freine
l'embauche mais quand on est en
situation de quasi pleine emploi est-ce
que est-ce que c'est ça un si grave
problème
alors vous avez raison situation de
pleine emploi le les choses se posent
d'une façon assez différente néanmoins
néanmoins les emplois qui sont menacés
par des fortes augmentations du SMIC sur
les emplois de personnes fragiles peu
qualifiées les souligner deux choses
d'abord si on veut régler un outil comme
le SMIC des problèmes d'écart de prix du
logement on se trompe d'outils il y a
des politiques de logement en France 50
milliards d'euros seront mis sur la
table chaque année à peu près pour
développer des politiques de logement
c'est ces politiques là qui doivent
répondre à un coût du logement qui peut
être très différent d'une région à une
autre d'une ville à une autre etc faut
pas se tromper par ailleurs il faut bien
voir que s'ajoutent au SMIC et la France
est un pays très très particulier pour
cela nous avons le salaire minimum et
pouvoir d'achat
ce langage un peu technique le plus
élevé de tous les pays d'ocde mais on
ajoute à ce salaire minimum des
prestations qui sont assez importantes
par exemple un salarié à temps plein
célibataire qui a le droit aux logements
la prime d'activité c'est plus de 240
euros par mois plus de 240 euros par
mois qui s'ajoute quand même comme comme
ressources et ça s'ajoute encore les APL
etc les aides de logement évidemment ça
fait pas des personnes concernées des
lentilles loin de là loin de là mais la
situation quand même est largement prise
en charge en compte par la collectivité
et ce qu'il faut surtout faire ces deux
choses d'une part accompagner les gens
pour qu'ils sortent du SMIC vous voyez
que quelqu'un que des personnes ne
respectent pas durablement c'est ça qui
est dramatique et l'autre point quand on
s'intéresse à la pauvreté au travail qui
sont les pauvres parmi les travailleurs
c'est pas des gens qui sont maintenant
c'est des gens qui sont
et là on touche à des situations
dramatiques et si on veut s'intéresser à
la pauvreté laborieuse il faut parler de
temps ciel de partielle contrainte parmi
les 17 % de temps partiel et la 40% qui
sont contraints souvent des familles
monoparentales avec des charges de
famille très fortes
pour essayer de réduire de lutter contre
les situations le temps partiel
contrainte qui est un facteur de
pauvreté premier
juste pour finir un point
quand on s'intéresse aux principaux
facteurs de pauvreté des travailleurs le
premier facteur de pauvreté des
travailleurs c'est le nombre d'heures
travaillés le deuxième c'est la
configuration familiale c'est plus
évidemment on a plus de chance d'être
pauvres quand on a cinq bouches à
nourrir
qu'on en a une ou deux et le salaire
horaire je rappelle que le SMIC est un
salaire horaire vient très très loin
derrière voyez faut pas se tromper de
cible en quelque sorte on peut parler de
sujets sur la table le temps partiel
subit la question du logement social
aussi après tout à Paris regarder elle
est dans les clous hein on est à 20%
c'est la loi SRU 20% et on entend ces
francilien on voit bien que ça résout
pas le problème vous renvoyez tout à la
conférence sociale ce sont des
partenaires sociaux qui doivent prendre
tout sera pas réglé par la Conférence
sociale dans notre pays c'est pourtant
quand même un élément important de
remettre tous les acteurs les
partenaires précisément moi j'en attends
que l'on puisse avoir effectivement un
meilleur partage de la valeur et une
augmentation des salaires dans ce pays
ça me semble et être important et
très très faible en France
c'est possible en France le problème
c'est ça c'est que et je les dis tout à
l'heure en introduction vous avez des
gens qui commencent au SMIC et qui
finissent au SMIC et en plus comme vous
l'a dit votre expert vous avez des gens
qui commencent au SMIC mais pas en temps
complet et qui reste longtemps en temps
en temps
ça sera fini ça le sujet non mais le
sujet et on voit bien qu'aussi le plein
emploi l'activité économique fait que
les salaires augmentent ils augmentent
certainement pas assez parce qu'on est
dans un choc du prix de l'énergie on est
dans un choc de l'inflation aujourd'hui
donc c'est c'est très conjoncturel mais
structurellement si l'économie va mieux
et si l'économie va bien les salaires
augmentent et dernier point dernier
point parce que je pense que c'est le
point crucial et je reviens c'est la
question du logement c'est la question
du logement il faut qu'on ait plus de
logements sociaux là ces dames qui ne
parlaient tout à l'heure qui sont dans
des situations qui qui crèvent le cœur
vu les prix de loyer qu'elles avaient
elles étaient sans doute pas voir
certainement pas dans un logement social
et c'est des salaires vous le savez bien
voilà la liste est longue donc la
question de bâtir bâtir du logement
social de qualité qui permet un logement
digne un logement qui permet
d'accueillir ses enfants sereinement
c'est une priorité également le plus
grave je trouve c'est que ces personnes
qu'on a vu qui sont les les salariés de
première ligne métier de la santé métier
de la petite enfance métier du troisième
âge ils vivent pas en Île-de-France ils
sont en dehors de la frontière et
viennent travailler ici et ça c'est pas
normal
Christophe Césaire vous parlez de
d'usine à gaz sur le logement on va pas
résoudre tout avec ça mais nous on a une
proposition de simplification sur le bas
et d'avoir un bail beaucoup plus
simplifié qu'on peut révoquer beaucoup
plus rapidement en fait répondre aux
problèmes des logements vacants on a 10%
de logements vacants en moyenne sur le
territoire y compris à Paris il y a
aussi des impôts locatifs qui sont
prohibitifs pour les propriétaires sur
le sur le marché à l'achat et la
question des droits des droits de
mutation à titre onéreux pas onéreux
nous on propose de supprimer tout ça un
bail simplifié permettre au propriétaire
de récupérer plus rapidement sont bien
de permettre là moi je me je m'inscris
complètement en faux j'ai l'exemple dans
ma circonscription en ce moment de
quelque chose qui me fend le cœur de
propriétaire d'une d'une maison de
retraite qui en 15 jours demande à leur
à leur résidence s'en aller donc des
baux qui seraient encore plus simple et
qui seraient encore moins protecteur du
locataire moi je vous dis tout de suite
en tout cas c'est intéressant parce que
c'est un tour de piste de ce proposition
il y a une conférence sociale qui va
commencer là le mois prochain d'un mot
alors juste en quelques mots voilà nous
on fait une demande très concrète on a
42 demandes je sais que
erwanant fait est issu d'un groupe qui
est très décentralisateur et j'espère
que le Président de la République
acceptera le débat sur toutes ces
demandes il faut la voir ça et les
partenaires sociaux sont en première
ligne sur ce sujet on va s'arrêter là
merci d'avoir participé à ce débat Merci
à VOUS Gilbert 7 pour votre expertise à
distance on vous on vous rappellera
c'est sûr dès qu'on parle de Smic vous
êtes le meilleur allez vous restez avec
moi Benjamin Stora dans une dizaine de
minutes les parties pris de nos
affranchis ce soir il Goose qui on est
ravi d'accueillir il va nous parler de
la planification écologique c'est la fin
d'une longue attente le regard du
philosophe Pierre-Henri tavoyau sur les
polémiques récentes autour de la laïcité
et puis le roi forcément dans Bourbon
Express ce soir c'est bien ça Stéphanie
oui je vais vous parler du Discours d'un
roi celui d'Angleterre évidemment devant
les députés et sénateurs réunis mais
d'abord Benjamin Stora on va plonger
dans vos mémoires c'est un peu mauvais
mémoires c'est son beau souvenir
l'arrivée de Constantine à Paris c'est
chez Taillandier ça raconte l'exode
précipité l'arrachement de vos parents
auquel vous rendez hommage
l'assimilation l'émancipation aussi dans
une société française des trentes
glorieuses parfois hostile mais aussi
généreuse on voit ça dans l'invitation
de Marion Becker on en parle ensemble
juste après
si on vous invite Benjamin Stora c'est
parce que vous vous livrez pour la
première fois en racontant votre enfance
les mémoires d'un gamin qui quittent
l'Algérie pour découvrir un nouveau
monde la France un périple de
Constantine à Paris en retraçant ses dix
années de votre jeunesse vous racontez
aussi à quel point vos origines
familiales ont déterminé votre parcours
intellectuel car Benjamin Stora vous
êtes historien spécialiste de la guerre
d'Algérie vous y avez consacré de
nombreux ouvrages en 2020 Emmanuel
Macron vous confiait une mission sur la
mémoire de la colonisation et de la
guerre d'Algérie
cette fois vous racontez votre propre
histoire celle de votre famille juive à
Constantine en Algérie l'arrachement à
votre terre natale le 16 juin 1962 vous
embarquez en silence pour la France avec
votre famille et huit balises
à Paris vous découvrez la pauvreté
l'antisémitisme dans le très chic lycée
Jean sonde Sailly vous expliquez alors
comment il vous a fallu oublier et
dissimuler votre propre histoire pour
vivre dans la société française pour
surmonter les épreuves de l'exil ce
récit s'est aussi celui de
l'assimilation et de la superposition
des identités dans l'insouciance des
années 60 en banlieue puis celle de
l'émancipation par l'engagement
politique à partir de mai 68 vous êtes
alors trots vous croyez en la Révolution
la déchéance sociale vécue par votre
famille ni sans doute pas étrangère
votre histoire vous rattrape à partir de
1974 vous commencez à travailler sur
l'histoire de l'Algérie après l'oubli
nécessaire vous devenez historien des
événements alors on a une question pour
vous Benjamin Stora l'historien que vous
êtes a-t-il été construit par votre
histoire intime
réponse réponse oui et non
l'historien que je suis c'est d'abord du
travail universitaire tout à fait
classique sur la base d'archives de
témoignages de presse etc mais on est
effectivement rattrapé par son histoire
intime c'est vrai peut-être c'est un
effet de vieillissement je sais pas ça a
pris du temps pour vous de décrire ce
livre c'est un livre personnel sans
doute le plus beau
vous y êtes depuis longtemps qu'est-ce
qui vous a décidé depuis plusieurs
années en fait parce que il y a eu
plusieurs plusieurs événements bien sûr
le problème de la transmission de cette
histoire à mon fils en particulier je
pense que c'est des choses qui sont
importantes les mutations de la société
française le rapport à la nation à la
France à l'immigration à l'exil qui
s'est profondément modifiée ça c'est
très important
il y a aussi bien sûr
toute la question des réflexions autour
de des questions coloniales post
coloniales bon le président Macron
m'avait confié cette mission si en 2021
qui est très important parce qu'elle
touche des millions des personnes qui
sont touchées par l'Algérie donc revenir
aux origines on va partir de cette photo
la couverture c'est qui ce petit garçon
de 11 ans au regard pétillant voilà
c'est léger se léger sourire qui grandit
dans les ores à Constantine dans un
quartier judéo musulman où l'on entend
l'arabe où l'on entend la France bien
sûr et on lit l'hébreu à quoi ressemble
la vie à l'époque c'est une vie
communautaire déjà c'est à dire une vie
de l'entre-soi où les gens de la
communauté juive vivaient entre eux bien
sûr la communauté musulmane les
chrétiens vous voyez j'utilise les
termes de l'époque pour qui sont
toujours utilisés par les personnes qui
sont qui ont vécu cette époque
évidemment
mais aussi une ville cosmopolite
forcément c'est à dire qu'on parlait
plusieurs langues sans même s'en
apercevoir c'était une richesse dont on
percevait pas évidemment toute
l'importance que ça aura plus tard pour
moi en particulier dans mes travaux
d'historien donc une vie d'entre soi une
vie de gaieté parce qu'il y a beaucoup
de fêtes dans les religions parce que
c'est c'était une ville religieuse
Constantine c'était pas Alger c'était
pas Oran il y avait il y a eu beaucoup
beaucoup de festivités religieuses
beaucoup de cousins
Marthe il y a des photos où on voit les
tentes et les cousins tout le monde se
réunites beaucoup de rites religieux et
ridiculaire lié au rythes religieux bien
évidemment puisque c'est c'est les fêtes
qui rythme disons les plats qu'on va
manger donc c'est cette villa bien sûr
il y a l'éruption de la guerre d'Algérie
quand même la peur vos parents est
particulièrement votre père il y a cru à
cette vie jusqu'au bout quelques mois
encore alors que ça devient très
compliqué notamment pour pour les Juifs
que son magasin c'est un atteindre
semoule pour les Juifs et boycotter les
tensions sont là ils continuent
d'ailleurs à employer ces deux personnes
musulmanes il y tient il y croit il y
croit parce que la famille est issue
d'une vieille région d'Algérie qui est
les Aurès et une autre partie de la
famille d'Alger bien sûr c'est à dire
qu'en fait les Juifs d'Algérie étaient
là depuis des siècles et des siècles
comment s'arracher à une vie aussi
ancienne c'était un dilemme extrêmement
cruel extrêmement difficile et puis mon
père aussi avait fait beaucoup d'études
en arabe littéraire et un diplôme de
droits musulmans de la faculté d'Alger
donc ils connaissait très bien cette
société
et donc pour lui ça paraissait quelque
chose d'impensable
pour la plupart d'ailleurs pour beaucoup
de gens ça paraissait impensable de
quitter l'Algérie parce que
effectivement
l'Algérie française il y avait eu le
décret Crémieux et la citoyenneté
française même si elle avait été arraché
enlever par Vichy néanmoins les Juifs
d'Algérie pensaient que cette égalité
citoyenne il ne pouvait pas la perdre
ils avaient peur d'ailleurs de la perdre
à nouveau alors ça sera pas le bateau
pour vous cette décision de départ ce
sera ce sera l'avion deux valises par
personne pas plus il faut tout laisser
derrière soi et vos parents vous votre
sœur vous prenez un d'abord un camion
militaire et puis jusqu'à l'aéroport
c'est le décollage personne ne parle
silence total et la nuit tombe c'est ça
votre dernière image en fait elle
n'existe pas en fait elle n'existe pas
la dernière image dans la mesure où on a
attendu longtemps sur le tarmac pour une
chaleur écrasante en portant des
manteaux parce que comme ça on gagnait
de la place dans les valises
et lorsque l'avion a décollé
effectivement bah la nuit est tombée
brusquement et il y a pas de j'ai pas de
souvenirs d'une dernière image de
l'Algérie de ce pays qui va disparaître
dans tous les sens du terme il va
disparaître rapidement c'est le sens de
ce livre d'ailleurs c'est à dire le fait
que pendant tout un temps ben il y avait
cette oublié c'est tout oublier de
l'Algérie leur moi comment font de 12
ans bien sûr ce qui était pas le cas de
mes parents qui étaient eux emportés par
le chagrin c'est ça qui est très
important pour vous ce départ il n'est
pas si douloureux mais vos parents sont
déjà âgés mon père à 53 ans ma mère 46
ans donc ils ont fait toute leur vie en
Algérie c'est beaucoup plus difficile
pour eux pour moi non c'est une
excitation il y a la découverte d'un
nouveau pays la France dont on parlait
beaucoup à l'école partout qu'on
connaissait pas dans le fond on n'avait
jamais été en France donc il y avait
effectivement cette cette nouveauté
sensationnelle qui se présentait devant
mes yeux et donc aller vers la ville
lumière alors justement c'est important
la ville lumière elle est sombre quand
c'est arrivé c'est un taudis alors dans
le 16e certes mais garage mis
appartement
mais entrepôt dans lequel vous vous
arrivez rien n'est prévu d'ailleurs pour
accueillir ce qu'on appelle les
rapatriés oui c'est-à-dire qu'en fait on
était mais on le disait pas comme ça à
l'époque on était en fait des réfugiés
c'est lorsque j'ai par exemple quand
j'ai vu les images à la télévision bien
sûr de jésus-crainiens qui quittait vous
savez les villes qui en guerre et je me
suis souvenu aussi de ce départ avec
deux valises sans rien et ne sachant pas
s'il y avait la possibilité du retour
donc c'était l'incertitude la précarité
absolue et effectivement on a atterri
dans un endroit improbable dans le 16e
arrondissement au cœur du 16e
arrondissement entre la rue du Docteur
Blanche et l'avenue Mozart donc c'était
quand même quartier très chic vous allez
rester deux ans scolarisé au lycée très
huppé de Janson saillie et là vous
raconter la honte de la pauvreté vous
racontez même
que vous faites semblant de rentrer chez
vous alors que c'est pas chez vous dans
de beaux immeubles parisiens pour que
vos camarades ne se doutent de rien oui
c'est-à-dire que dans cette exil
effectivement la question de la honte
sociale c'est imposée beaucoup plus dans
un premier temps que la question de la
perte d'identité
ou de la nostalgie du Père du Paradis
Perdu etc en fait la question sociale
avait tout envahi mes parents et mon
père en particulier ma mère aussi était
obsédée par la question sociale c'est à
dire trouver un travail trouver un
logement incroyable à l'usine Peugeot ma
mère a fini par devenir ouvrir d'usine à
l'usine Peugeot ou qui rit à La Garenne
Bezons et mon père bon grâce à son
diplôme en droit a pu travailler dans
une compagnie d'assurance mais c'était
une opérations entre guillemets de
survie sociale fondamentalement plus que
de souvenirs de traumatisme même si dans
l'espace privé familial en particulier
dans une grande famille le souvenir
naturellement lancinant terrible de
l’algérie revenait mais la question
sociale était très importante faut pas
l'oublier la question sociale la
question de l'antisémitisme aussi et
même si on oublie même si on est face
elle vous rattrape cette question là et
vous en faites l'expérience de façon
très différente de tout ce que vous avez
pu connaître en métropole dans le très
chic et 16e arrondissement oui
effectivement il y a une espèce entre
guillemets d'antisémitisme culturel
évident banal etc qui pousse d'ailleurs
à cette sorte entre guillemets de
dissimulation des origines c'est à dire
que c'est ce qu'on va appeler
l'assimilation c'est vrai c'est
l'assimilation c'est à dire ne pas
montrer du tout sa différence ne va
montrer qu'on vient d'Algérie donc il
faut effacer son accent bien sûr qui est
un accent très reconnaissable mais il y
a aussi bien sûr
l'identité juive bon qui qui va
s'effacer dans l'espace public alors
qu'elle était très présente
lorsque j'étais enfant donc c'est un
processus aussi qui qui s'accomplit dans
une modernisation très rapide de la
société française
la voiture la machine à laver la machine
elle avait les avions les aéroports les
autoroutes enfin bref on a une France
qui se modifie à une vitesse prodigieuse
comment vous vivez le regard qu'on porte
sur vous vous êtes perçu comme des
réfugiés dans votre propre pays comme
des réfugiés justement des étrangers non
plus on était ni des réfugiés ni des
étrangers ni des immigrés mais qu'est-ce
qu'on était alors on était des espèces
de français à part d'ailleurs ma mère
quand elle parlait souvent et mon père
aussi tout le monde de ma famille parler
des français quand il parlait des gens
de qui vivaient à côté de chez nous etc
c'est-à-dire on était à la fois français
sans être vraiment français c'est-à-dire
qu'on parlait français on aimait la
culture française bien sûr mais en même
temps on n'était pas vu véritablement
comme des Français c'est toute la
difficulté de s'entre-deux qui était
très compliqué et les années ça
retrouvait après les années 50
le vélo le football la culture ouvrière
que je découvre bien sûr ça va de Jean
Ferrat jusqu'au Tour de France c'est
c'est là que je rencontre le Parti
communiste français aussi qui est très
fort très puissant à Sartrouville et
donc il y a une fraternité nouvelle qui
qui existe à l'intérieur des cités
ouvrières de cette époque sans
distinction d'origine identitaire
ethnique ou autre tous les enfants tous
les adolescents de cette époque qui
jouent au football ou qui font du vélo
qui font des sorties etc ne se préoccupe
pas de l'identité première ça c'est très
important ce qui va expliquer aussi
entre guillemets l'oubli c'est-à-dire
que on a aussi une volonté d'avancer
dans une société qui se modernise très
vite sans sans référence à l'identité de
départ d'assignation sans assignation
absolument l'éveil politique vous l'avez
dit déjà les premiers contacts avec le
communisme et ce Benjamin saura dont les
cheveux commencent à pousser de plus en
plus dans les années 70
Nanterre où vous allez découvrir
l'histoire commencer à vous tourner
votre l'Algérie d'histoire de l'Algérie
ça commence déjà là mais 68 l'extrême
gauche le lambertisme le trotisme vous
avez un blaze d'abord un blaze
soviétique puis ensuite vous devenez
russe vous devenez Truffaut c'est
l'émancipation la véritable qu'est-ce
que vous en gardez de ces années là en
quoi elles vous ont encore marqué
aujourd'hui le participe d'un processus
d'assimilation culturelle en fait
rentrer aussi dans cette histoire
française que je connaissais pas cette
histoire qui va de la Commune de Paris
jusqu'à la résistance etc donc c'est une
suite en fait fondamentalement d'autre
part c'est une sécurité une parce que il
y avait une incertitude quand même
sociale
qui a une fraternité qui se crée dans le
réseau militant qui est très fort parce
que on était un petit groupe à Nanterre
on était très solidaire entre nous et il
y avait beaucoup beaucoup de groupes à
l'époque à Nanterre c'est pas les seuls
évidemment mais ça crée cette sorte de
convivialité de vivre ensemble de
chaleur humaine que je retrouvais dans
le fond que j'avais pas vraiment
découvert dans les lycées où j'avais été
et que je retrouvais là cette fois-ci
spontanée et l'idéal cette radicalité
c'était une forme aussi de revanche sur
des classements des parents et il y a
effectivement une radicalité sur la qui
pourrait prendre sa rétrospectivement
que je l'ai analysé dans ce livre
effectivement par rapport aux
déclassement la chute vertigineuse
sociale de mes parents il y a une rage
effectivement sociale qui est très forte
moi j'étais fils d'ouvrier en fait
fondamentalement ce qui était pas le cas
de tous mes camarades
je vous invite à lire l'arrivée on
parlera de la question de la mémoire
plus tard vous reviendrez parce que
voilà les tensions sont encore très
dures très difficiles entre la France et
l'Algérie de Constantine à Paris
1962-1972 chez Taillandier le plus beau
livre je trouve de Benjamin Stora vous
restez avec moi c'est l'heure des
parties pris des affranchis ils vont
vous faire réagir on les accueille tout
de suite
éditorialiste à France Inter bienvenue
dans cette émission vous aurez désormais
un parti pris politique le jeudi soir
dans Ça vous regarde installez-vous
Pierre-Henri tavoyau qu'on est ravi de
retrouver cette saison du collège de
philosophie on va commencer par Bourbon
Express Bourbon Royal ce soir forcément
l'histoire de du jour à l'Assemblée elle
s'est passé du côté du Sénat mais les
députés y étaient bonsoir Stéphanie
Despierre alors comment l'ont-ils trouvé
Charles III alors je vais vous le
raconter Myriam mais avant je vous
propose de regarder ces quelques images
parce que c'était un moment historique
pour la première fois un roi anglais a
fait un discours à la tribune du
Parlement français alors sa Majesté
Charles III était accueilli en grande
pompe sous les ordres de la République
par yelbron Pivet présidente de
l'Assemblée et Gérard Larcher il a salué
toute une délégation de députés et de
sénateurs alors protocole oblige c'était
tenu correct exigé mais rien de trop
difficile et pas tous
révérence nous ne sommes pas des sujets
de Sa et puis vous le voyez devant un
parterre de 300 parlementaires il a fait
un long discours chaque groupe politique
était invité ils étaient tous là et les
bancs ressemblaient un peu à un fan club
regardez cette photo et bien voilà fini
les débats sur les portables les photos
dans l'hémicycle tout le monde voulait
sa photo du roi alors qu'est-ce qu'il a
dit le roi Charles et bien elle a fait
un discours très politique en 18 minutes
en alternant avec une grande aisance le
français et l'anglais Charles III n'a eu
l'idée aucun des sujets du moment sauf
peut-être le brexit il a parlé du crâne
on expliquant que l'alliance entre la
France et le Royaume-Uni étaient plus
importantes que jamais alors que la
guerre est de retour sur le sol européen
puis il a parlé d'environnement on le
sait si un sujet qui lui tient à co à
coeur il a proposé une nouvelle entente
climatique au parlementaire français
pour un monde plus durable et puis
évidemment il a célébré cette amitié
franco britannique sur un ton
volontariste et optimiste
et notre alliance sont plus importants
importantes que jamais
tout simplement le Royaume-Uni sera
toujours un des allées les plus proches
et un des meilleurs amis de la France
allons de l'avant avec espoir et courage
et faisons-le ensemble
merci alors le roi a le droit à une
longue staning ovation presque deux
minutes d'applaudissement debout bref
une vraie lune de miel entre le roi et
la République pour quelques minutes ça a
même amusé Gérard Larcher le président
du Sénat qui était un peu jaloux quand
même qui nous ferait rêver madame la
Présidente respectifs
et les députés alors
député discours pardon très apprécié
même ceux de gauche
alors est-ce que vous député de gauche
ça vous a plu cette visite royale
effectivement moi député de gauche et
bien j'ai aimé le discours du roi donc
ce qui peut paraître contradictoire pour
une députée qui aime la République qui
suit à gauche mais en fait c'était un
discours à la fois qui portait sur les
enjeux d'aujourd'hui avec l'écologie
bien entendu et puis c'était un discours
qui remet le progrès à l'ordre du jour
politique et c'est un discours très très
politique pour vous les insoumis la
royauté c'est pas trop votre tasse de
thé c'était comment ce discours ce matin
prononcé par un chef d'État ami c'était
légitime que ça existe le confort
représenté voilà un chef d'État s'est
adressé un peuple par l'intermédiaire de
ses représentants c'était un moment
finalement agréable
un moment finalement agréable du bout
des lèvres mais c'est dit sa Majesté
Charles III aura donc accompli un petit
miracle à réconcilier quelques heures
durant la gauche et la monarchie merci
Stéphanie comment vous regardez ces
images en historien ça vous attendrisse
cette espèce de grande entente cordiale
entre les députés républicains et le roi
britannique et se rassemblement unitaire
de l'ensemble de la du spectre politique
c'est quelque chose de très étrange
d'autant que en ce moment on discute
beaucoup de Robespierre la Révolution
française de couper des têtes dans tous
les débats politiques publiques et puis
tout d'un coup le roi arrive et nous
voilà dans une sorte de rassemblement
national c'est très surprenant
sincère ou pas je sais pas on se pose la
question Yaël on enchaîne avec vous
alors après Charles III le Mondial de
rugby le pape qui arrive samedi
l'inflation et bien la planification
écologique on la croyait complètement
enterrée pourtant ça avance ça avance ça
Myriam même si il a fallu être un peu
patient parce que ce plan aurait dû le
connaître cet été au mois de juillet les
émeutes le remaniement tout ça à décaler
l'agenda mais on y est lundi dernier
Elisabeth borne la première ministre
elle a vu les chefs de partie elle leur
a montré les les fameux graphiques les
camemberts les courbes les petits
histogrammes le Tetris coloré qui nous
dit ce qu'on doit faire d'ici à 2030
réduire et comment de 55% nos émissions
de CO2 et on attend maintenant lundi
prochain le grand discours du président
celui qui doit résonner avec sa promesse
de campagne 2022 vous souvenez à
Marseille mon quinquennat sera
écologique ou ne le sera pas deux points
positifs le premier c'est qu'on a un
consensus politique qui s'est dégagé sur
ces chiffres de la décarbonation
autrement dit plus personne ne remet en
question les objectifs donc la science
et ça c'est quand même assez rare en ce
moment très polarisé et c'est un plan
qui nous dépasse nos français puisque la
trajectoire elle est européenne et le
deuxième point positif cocorico la
France fait de la notifications
écologique avec une équipe dédiée
rattachée à Matignon qui balise la route
pour guider le politique et ça c'est
inédit alors il y a plus qu'à maintenant
et c'est là que le consensus s'arrête
Myriam parce que s'agit de savoir
maintenant comment on fait pour arriver
à faire plus en l'espace de 7 ans que ce
qui a été déjà fait en 33 ans voilà il
faut accélérer c'est ça l'enjeu mais
maintenant il faut savoir quel moyen
quel milliard pour electrifier une
économie à vitesse grand V c'est ça
aussi l'enjeu l'électricité et comment
répartit l'effort et j'ai bien dit le
mot effort or Emmanuel Macron tout son
défi c'est d'assurer le portage
politique du changement faire que cette
transition ne soit pas vécue comme subi
mais comme désirable et ça ça reste
difficile pourquoi on va on va sans
arrêt alterner entre des sentiments
contraires soit le refus d'obstacle
c'est trop dur on a peur et la peur ça
paralyse soit à l'inverse la fois
exagérée dans une science une
technologie qui ne serait qu'on n'est
pas à changer nos comportements c'est
utopique aussi c'est impossible d'un
côté une tentation du à quoi bon
pourquoi en faire autant si la France
permet que 1% du CO2 mondial et de
l'autre côté au contraire la volonté de
tirer les autres avec nous
universalistes et français de montrer
l'exemple le problème là maintenant tout
de suite c'est qu'on est toujours bloqué
dans cette entre deux fin du mois fin du
monde vous avez vu comment le
gouvernement est à la peine sur
l'inflation comment il cherche la
formule magique impossible pour baisser
le prix des carburants l'urgence de
court terme du pouvoir d'achat percute
le travail de ces planificateurs dont on
parle pour qui l'urgence c'est au
contraire de se désintoxiquer au plus
vite du pétrole mais sans le signal prix
comment vous faites pour vous
désintoxiquer changer les comportements
il va falloir aussi très vite Myriam un
plan pour surmonter toutes nos
contradictions capables ou pas capable à
votre avis ce sera très difficile
surtout la question d'électricité
c'était de Lénine qui disait pour
construire la société voulait Soviets
plus l'électricité et ben voilà on
revient il a
toujours pris la pompe qu'on regarde sur
le prix de du kilowatt-heure aussi alors
on va terminer avec vous Pierre Henry de
l'interdiction de la Baya à la visite du
pape à Marseille demain on l'a vu cette
rentrée elle est chargée en matière de
laïcité vous vouliez revenir là-dessus
oui c'est chargé c'est aussi une très
grande moment de confusion des esprits
parce que les mêmes qui s'offusquaient
de l'interdiction de la Baya s'étrangle
littéralement de voir notre président
assisté à la messe à Marseille avec le
Pape et donc on a là une très très
grande confusion des esprits et l'idée
que font cette laïcité c'est quand même
de la l'islamophobie un peu caché et que
il y a deux poids de mesure on interdit
tout ce qui relève de l'islam et on
vénère tout ce qui relève de la
chrétienté et donc en effet il y a un
problème alors en quoi ces apparences
sont trompés selon vous
rappeler une chose importante le
contraire de la laïcité c'est pas la
religion c'est le fondamentaliste le
fondamentalisme c'est quoi c'est la
volonté de réjonter la totalité de la
sphère privée de la sphère existentielle
de la sphère des individus sous une
seule loi
la loi de Dieu je cite quand même cette
petite phrase de Voltaire dans le
fanatisme article fanatisme de son
Dictionnaire philosophique que répondre
à un homme qui vous dit qu'il est mieux
obéir à Dieu qu'aux hommes et qui ont
conséquence est sûr de mériter le ciel
on vous égorgeant
l'assassinat de Samuel Paty a montré que
c'était pas là un mot d'esprit contre le
fondamentalisme nos sociétés libérales
considèrent qu'il n'y a pas que la
religion dans la vie mais qu'il y a en
vérité trois sphères qu'il faut bien
distinguer parce qu'il y a un chapitre
un principe pour chacun de chacune de
ces trois sphères sur privé c'est la
liberté liberté de croire de ne pas
croire de changer de religion ni les
résines il apostasie ni la théiste ne
sont des crimes se faire public l'État
ne reconnaît ni une subventionne aucun
culte et au nom du Salut public il faut
se désintéresser du salut privé et la
troisième et la troisième qu'on oublie
la sphère de la civilité c'est le
principe de la discrétion du respect
d'autrui des égards ni espacement
excessif ni provocation outrancière
c'est la condition de la pas du vivre
ensemble on dit souvent le vivant sans
mettre de la vie commune parce qu'on
veut vivre ensemble côte à côte ou face
à face la vie commune c'est le vouloir
vivre ensemble c'est important alors
liberté neutralité discrétion si je vous
suis bien tRILOG Trinité qui clarifie
suffisamment les choses je crois parce
qu'on en fait les grandes querelles de
la laïcité sont toujours sur la question
des frontières entre ces trois sphères
frontières subtiles voyez la question de
la Baya la Baya c'est de dire bah c'est
ma vie privée j'ai le droit de
m'habiller comme je veux j'ai le droit
d'être pudique de cacher mon corps oui
mais on oublie que cet abaya pudique
pour le corps est un exhibitionnisme
religieux qui vise à faire pression sur
les autres et à entreprendre une
stratégie de conquête du monde scolaire
et donc en effet c'est tabaya relève de
la loi de 1904 qui interdit de 2004 qui
interdit les signes les manifestations
ostensibles d'appartenance religieuse
surtout quand elle se manifeste voilà
c'est ça le mot important le président
de son côté c'est le même principe
est-ce que c'est privé est-ce que c'est
public est-ce qu'il est
dévotion personnelle ou représentation
nationale et bien en l'occurrence oui on
peut dire qu'il est à Marseille il sera
à Marseille comme un président il y a
des présidents qui ont assisté à des
messes il y a des présidents qui de
Gaulle notamment il y a aussi des signes
non pas de dévotion mais de marques de
respect quand on entre dans une
synagogue on prend une qui pas comme au
long de l'avait fait en 2015 avec les
après les attentats quand on rentre dans
une mosquée on enlève ces chaussures
c'est une marque de respect c'est pas un
signe de dévotion donc ce n'est pas des
atteintes à la laïcité ce sont on peut
objecter politiquement que c'est pas au
courant
mais ce n'est pas une atteinte à la
laïcité merci pour ce parti pris
d'accord avec ça ça vous choque pas
Emmanuel Macron le drone pour la messe
avec le Pape avec le fait qu'il y ait
une loi c'est la loi de 2004 donc il
faut l'appliquer tout simplement et ne
pas rajouter encore des débats sur la
base du doigt qui existe déjà et le
président
le président au Vélodrome à la grande
messe je crois que c'est François
Mitterrand qui avait dit avant de mourir
une messe peut-être dites si mes
souvenirs sont dangereux absolument
celui qui voulait croire en force de
l'esprit on s'arrête là merci beaucoup
Benjamin Stora de nous avoir accompagné
une heure en direct ce soir l'arrivée de
Constantine à Paris est à lire aux
éditions thaïlandais merci les
affranchers à très vite je crois même
demain on vous retrouve pour ce pour ce
débat à l'occasion de la visite du pape
François et de cette grande messe où est
le Drôme en présence d'Emmanuel Macron a
très vite aussi Stéphanie Despierre
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi pour l'avoir pour la
revoir la chaîne Youtube LCP bien sûr
très belle soirée à demain
[Musique]